[Music]
well the new york times
used to be considered
the paper of record and uh it still is
only now it's a record of our cultural
decay
the times may no longer you know have
the same level of prestige or
credibility or any level of procedure
credibility at all but as an unwitting
chronicle of decadence it still has some
sort of relevance arguably case in point
the article written by pulitzer
prize-winning journalist dania issawi uh
isawi
is awi let's call her i think i'll go
with that yeah that's that sounds right
dania isawi anyway the article is titled
can't talk i'm busy being hot a social
media movement inspired by the rapper
megan the stallion strikes back at the
gatekeepers of beauty
now you of course are already expecting
that this is going to be pretty bad
given that it's in the new york times
and it's about hotness and it mentions
megan the stallion
but i assure you
it's so much worse than you anticipate
it begins
uh edwina esteem was wearing a heavy
shapeless graduation gown it was the
color of charcoal and it reached all the
way down to her ankles and yet she had
never felt hotter as she crossed the
stage to accept her diploma she heard
the cheers from friends and family
members she was graduating from law
school and that to her was extremely hot
that was a three-year process said miss
esteem
uh estimate probably 26 who earned her
degree this spring from the shepherd
broads college of law at uh no nova
southeastern university and davey i
there's so many words in here that i'm
not able to pronounce three years of
waking up and not feeling hot for me to
get to that one day where i'm like wow
this is hot this is what's hot for me
right now she added she is one of many
who are expanding the definition of
hotness taking it beyond its former
association with old notions of
attractiveness
these days being hot no longer pertains
only to your physical appearance but
includes how you move through the world
and how you see yourself
now if you're thinking
did this pulitzer prize-winning
journalist really just go around
interviewing random people about times
when they felt hot and then wrote an
article about it for the new york times
and the new york times actually
published it
the answer is no she didn't just go
around interviewing them she also
watched their instagram and tick tock
videos
this was a full journalistic
investigation i assure you no stone was
left unturned to find all of the hot
people
continuing
many of those pushing for a broader
understanding of the term are also
pushing back against the idea that you
need to wait for confirmation from
someone else before feeling justified in
calling yourself hot to them hotness is
a self-declaration and that's that
hotness is no longer just in the eye of
the beholder
it's a mood it's a vibe emily sunderberg
a 28 year old editor and filmmaker in
brooklyn was eating spaghetti when she
had a realization
she was being hot there was nothing
glamorous about it it was just a solo
weeknight dinner at the kitchen counter
and miss sunberg was wearing workout
clothes and glasses but she felt moved
to make a video of herself as she
twirled the pasta strands into a fork
and succeeded in getting most of them
all the way into her mouth as she chewed
with kanye west's jail blaring in the
background she stared into the lens with
a blank expression miss sunberg then
posted the seven second video to
instagram stories quote you don't have
to ask for permission to be hot online
ms sunberg said you could take up space
and perform and create your own power
dynamics between yourself and your
audience i think being hot online is
sort of pure and debatably what social
media was originally for
that's why it was invented
with to be hot online it's true i had a
similar realization last night when i
was standing at the fridge at 11 30 p.m
um
opening the container with my daughter's
leftover chicken tenders which we'd
ordered for her at the restaurant
earlier in the evening but she hadn't
touched
and then i was eating them cold along
with her side of mac and cheese which i
also ate cold and without a fork and as
i was consuming all the leftovers that
my wife specifically said she wanted to
save for lunch the following day which i
also agreed should be saved for lunch
even as i knew in my head that i would
almost certainly be eating all of them
in a gluttonous and shameful late-night
binge
i too in that moment came to the
realization that i was being hot
but then i realized that i was actually
just feeling a heartburn that's so sorry
getting confused sometimes and so i took
some tums and went to bed i only wish
that the new york times had called me so
that i could tell them about this
experience i would have loved to share
it with them
now you may think there's no reason to
continue reading from this times article
and you're right
but we will anyway so here's more quote
a phenomenon started by the tic toc
influencer mia lind encourages young
women to go on four mile walks while
remaining focused on self-affirming
thoughts in three areas what they're
grateful for their goals in life and how
they plan to accomplish them and how hot
they are miss lin says
you may not think of any boys or any boy
drama she said in a video that laid out
the ground rules in an interview she
said that she wanted to un-gatekeep the
feeling of being hot with her hot girl
walk
taking it away from male gaze arbiters
who treat daily life like some kind of
beauty pageant
being hot is really accessible more
accessible than previously thought said
miss lind who created megan the stallion
as it accredited her as an inspiration
for the walk i think there's a really
big reclamation of the term hot the hot
girl walk has maintained its popularity
since miss lin posted her explanation
video which has accrued nearly 3 million
videos more than a year ago the hashtag
hot girl walk has racked up more than
280 million views
now like you i
wish i could go back in time and
throw myself off of a bridge before i'm
ever forced to hear the phrase
un-gatekeep the feeling of being hot
but it's too late now we've been exposed
all we can do now is
find a way to move forward and maybe try
to make some sense of all of this if we
can so here's how i make sense of it
first one of the hallmarks of a decadent
society and this is explained quite
eloquently in the book the decadent
society which you should read if you
haven't
is that it repeats itself
it runs out of
new ideas and just starts recycling
old ideas over and over again and we
find this of course in hollywood and pop
culture but we also find it in articles
like this here we have the stunning and
revolutionary idea that the definition
of beauty should be expanded and that
confidence and self-affirmation are
important
truly this is the first time the world
has ever encountered such notions
the first time since the last time
anyway and the last time was 15 seconds
before this article was published and 15
seconds before that and every 15 seconds
for the past 30 years at least
i mean this is the same message we've
heard on repeat for decades randomly
presented as something different and
unique all of a sudden
and because it's a times article in the
year 2022 the issue of course has also
been arbitrarily racialized because
we're told at the end of the piece quote
rachel elizabeth weissler a researcher
at the university of oregon specializing
in linguistics and black studies said
the many words and phrases that become
common in online discourse including hot
on fleek and kiki are rooted in bipoc
and queer communities over time they
become co-opted and come to be seen as
elements of tick-tock speak she said a
phenomenon she referred to as semantic
bleaching she credited me on the
stallion as a source of the memes
promoting self-affirming messages for
young women and girls citing her 2020
song body quote we saw meg come out with
body during quarantine it's going to be
and she said it's going to be a hot girl
summer we're going to be happy we're
going to be confident women a lot of our
language change comes from women it
comes from black people and also from
people of color
so the word hot by the way has been used
in english to denote physical
attractiveness for at least like a
hundred years
paris hilton made her catchphrase 20
years ago
and yet megan the stallion as a rep as a
representative of bipoc and queer
communities quote unquote gets credit as
a source for the concept because of a
song she made two years ago
as the author of the approximately 90
millionth pop song about hotness she is
somehow now a pioneer she invented it
now in my opinion not to get into too
much semantics here um if anyone should
get credit as a pop pioneer because of
self-affirming odes to hotness it should
be the revolutionary musicians known as
wright said fred who 30 years ago
produced the playful yet poetic anthem
i'm too sexy and the world has really
never been the same sense in my opinion
and yet the thing you notice about all
this
self-affirmation and supposed confidence
as always is just how unconvincing it is
all of these people on social media you
know declare their hotness to the world
but the salient fact is that they're
declaring it to the world right they
they feel the need to declare it if you
were really secure and really confident
in and about yourself and your body you
wouldn't feel compelled to announce it
on social media young women don't post
selfies on instagram or videos on tick
tock because they feel beautiful they do
it because they want to feel beautiful
and they're depending on the world to
tell them that they're beautiful
this is not self-affirmation but
affirmation through likes and comments
and shares which is the opposite of
self-affirmation it's the same reason
they listen to unintelligible pop songs
by semi-literate idiots like meghan the
stallion
they want to be put into this kind of
trance-like state where they can believe
themselves to be cool and attractive for
three minutes at a time and that's the
primary function of modern pop music by
the way to provide mantras for
desperately insecure people
and there are a lot of desperately
insecure people describing themselves in
ways that they want to be seen
right this is how they want to be seen
and need to be seen
because despite their pretensions
they depend on the world's affirmation
and spend their entire lives seeking it
and that is why finally i guess
the new york times
for i'm told the third time is cancelled
they still haven't gotten the message so
we're going to keep trying
well before you go hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated